la veille du confinement
la compagnie illicites dance décide
d'enregistrer un flash mob et quelques
vidéos de chorégraphies pour faire
passer le temps à leurs élèves
quelques jours plus tard elle décide de
proposer des ateliers en visioconférence
j'ai commencé au début par par créer des
petites chorégraphies et les envoyer aux
personnes intéressées et finalement très
vite pour le continent a commencé à
durer plus il y avait de la demande donc
je me suis dit en effet pourquoi pas
ouvrir des ateliers en live ça s'est
beaucoup développée du coup en ce moment
en plus j'ai vu pas mal sur les réseaux
ailleurs donc je dis parfois pourquoi
pas nous tous les élèves se connecte sur
une application pour rejoindre l'atelier
au programme des échauffements du
renforcement musculaire et
l'apprentissage d'une nouvelle
chorégraphie
je pense que ça fait du bien à tout le
monde de faire un petit peu de sport et
puis puis de s'amuser puisque je pense
que la danse le cercle ça fait faire un
peu de sport mais c'est aussi un moyen
de décompresser de penser à rien d'autre
pendant une heure une heure et demie et
est donc et puis on sent bien que ça
fonctionne que depuis qu'on a lancé et
d'ateliers s'affranchirait plutôt plutôt
bien pour adeline assurer une continuité
des ateliers était primordial pour le
bien-être de ses élèves pendant le
confinement les visio conférences sont
ouvertes à tout le monde
en plus des adhérents de la compagnie on
peut continuer justement a créé alors
apprendre des choses et ça développe
autre chose des ateliers se déroulent à
partir de 19 heures les lundis pour les
adultes et les mardis pour les
adolescents et à 17 heures les mercredis
pour les enfants pendant une heure et
demie les participants peuvent
transpirer en toute sécurité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à tort